>> Mark: IT'S FRIDAY AND THAT
MEANS IT'S TIME FOR DAN BONGINO
TO EXPLODE.
THIS SHOWS FAVORITE FORMER COP
AND ALSO THE BOOK "EXONERATED:
THE FAILED TAKEDOWN OF
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP BY THE
SWAMP" IS HERE TO ROUND UP HIS
TOP STORIES OF THE WEEK.
GO GET THEM, DAN.
>> THANK YOU, MARK.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
LET'S START WITH STORY NUMBER
THREE.
I'VE BEEN GETTING AWFULLY TIRED
OF THIS FAKE, FAUX IMPEACHMENT,
NOT IMPEACHMENT, DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU WANT TO CALL THIS THING.
A BUNCH OF G.O.P. CONGRESSMEN
GOT A LITTLE BIT TESTED AT THIS
THING TOO AND TRIED TO STORM THE
GATES!
OF A SECRET HEARING MADAME ALEC
ADAM SCHIFF AND JERRY NADLER
WERE HOLDING.
I'VE NEVER SEEN IMPEACHMENT LIKE
THIS IN MY LIFE.
THE CONSTITUTION IS PRETTY
CLEAR.
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES HAS
THE SOLE POWER TO IMPEACH.
DOESN'T SAY JERRY NADLER, ADAM
SCHIFF, THE SPEAKER,
NANCY PELOSI, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES -- PLURAL, MARK!
I KNOW WE HAVE A TOUGH TIME WITH
ENGLISH AND THINGS, BUT PLURAL.
>> Mark: YOU AREN'T SUPPOSED
TO IMPEACH THE GUY -- THEY
THOUGHT STORMING THE ADAM SCHIFF
STAFF TIP WAS THE WORST THINGS
AND STORMING BASTILLE.
REVOLUTION REDIRECT!
>> WE NEED CELL PHONES OUTSIDE
OF THE SKIFF, WE NEED
CELL PHONES OUTSIDE!
GOOD CALL!
STORY NUMBER TWO, ARE WE LOOKING
AT TRY, TRY AGAIN, TRY AGAIN AND
AGAIN?
HILLARY 2020?
WHO KNOWS.
MARK, SOMETIMES IT'S TIME TO
TAKE A HINT.
GIVE THEM A LITTLE WINK, TIME TO
MOVE ON.
THIS THING MAY NOT BE FOR YOU.
IT WASN'T MY BAG OF DOUGHNUTS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
A STAFFER PHILLIPE RYAN KIND OF
HINTED ON OUR SHOWS THAT THERE
IS NOT A 0% CHANCE, SMALL CHANCE
THAT HILLARY COULD JUMP IN
AGAIN.
COULD YOU IMAGINE ANOTHER SHOT
AT THE TITLE FOR
HILLARY CLINTON?
>> Mark: COME ON!
NINTH TIME IS THE CHARM, DAN.
YOU KNOW IT!
>> SHE STILL HASN'T FIGURED OUT
THE RULES, MARK.
SHE THINGS THE POPULAR VOTE WINS
THE PRESIDENCY.
SHE STILL THINKS THE
ATLANTA BRAVES WON THE '96
WORLD SERIES BECAUSE THEY
OUTSCORED THEM THE FIRST TWO
GAMES.
YOU WANT TO GET THE RULES THEM
BEFORE YOU THINK ABOUT RUNNING
AGAIN.
JUST TO NOTE.
>> Mark: WHAT'S YOUR TOP STORY
THEN, DAN?
>> TOP STORY OF THE WEEK HAS GOT
TO BE JOHN BRENNAN WHO CLEARLY
IS DOWNING PEPTO-BISMOL LIKE
IT'S GATORADE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF FLORIDA FOOTBALL GAME.
THIS GUY IS TERRIFIED RIGHT NOW
AND MARK, HE'S TERRIFIED FOR ONE
BIG IMPORTANT REASON.
THIS GUY IS IN A LOT OF TROUBLE.
HE HAS SAID OPENLY AND PUBLICLY
ON NETWORKS, CABLE TV AND
OTHERWISE THAT HE DIDN'T SEE THE
DOSSIER UNTIL DECEMBER.
ANYBODY CAN READ IT, MARK.
BUT THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE BECAUSE
HE BRIEFED HARRY REID IN AUGUST,
WHICH LIBERALS HAVE A TOUGH TIME
WITH THE CALENDAR BEFORE
DECEMBER, AND WHEN HE BRIEFED
TALLEY REED, HARRY REID WROTE A
LETTER WITH THE FBI ABOUT THAT
BRIEFING CONTAINING INFORMATION,
MARK, THAT ONLY APPEARED MONTH
LATE, THE DOSSIER, BRENNAN SAID
HE DIDN'T SEE INTO DECEMBER.
IN SOME LIMITED CIRCLES, MARK,
WE CALL THAT A PROBLEM.
AND JOHNNY B IS IN A WORLD OF
TROUBLE RIGHT NOW.
GET THE PEPTO, JOHNNY.
YOU ARE GOING TO NEED IT.